[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: On July 8, 1853, residents
of Edo beheld an astonishing sight.
Four foreign warships had entered their
harbor under a cloud of black smoke.
Commodore Matthew Perry
of the United States
had arrived to force the
long secluded country
to open its doors to the outside world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 2: Imagine this scene.
Police boxes throughout the
city of Tokyo are destroyed.
Buildings and streetcars are torched.
The government responds
by declaring martial law.
It seems as if the recent war
with Russia has come home.
The Hibiya riot marked the
first major social protest
over the age of imperial democracy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 3: An elegantly
dressed European woman
holding a camellia blossom lies
luxuriously on a chaise lounge.
This could describe a French
image of a stylish Parisian,
but is, in fact, a 1920's Japanese
advertisement for the cosmetics company
Shiseido.
There is no Japanese company
whose advertising design better
represents cosmopolitan chic
in early 20th century Japan.
[MUSIC PLAYING]